my name is new group TV I'm draw
just briefly describe for us your work
how would you describe it to someone who
has never seen it before you see it i'm
i'm not good at describing this what you
see on it's like a nerd stories old in
its stories and sometimes life today
what we live today what our life was
like what it is like right now and
you're so well known for things like I'm
thinking of curious bear but also you're
known for doing modern the themes I'm
thinking of an image you did with a
Beatles record and a record player or
the image of Sedna smoking a cigarette
can you tell us why you're interested as
well in exploring sort of modern life in
Cape Dorset I've never really lived
there traditional a new life a different
time where my mum my mother was born
they lived out on the camp I live we
live in the community but we still go
out on the land that's this where I grew
up music like the Beatles different
generation and some artists even young
artists like you some of them have said
they're sort of scared to do more modern
imagery in their art scared of tackling
social issues in your art they're
worried it might not sell you seem not
to sort of have that that fear why is
that and sometimes I have a strong
feeling like the one you mentioned
sickness smoking it's a great
bottles around her pollution that's what
that's what I see even when we go
uploading you see garbage floating it's
not very nice and where did the the
image of sudden as smoking come from
what was it that you were trying to
convey in that piece or what was it that
inspired that piece it's not only the
our earth being polluted it's our
society drugs alcohol [ __ ] small
community and why do you think that's
important to portray in your art it's a
problem at the problem that needs to be
addressed and you know you do a lot of
art where we see a lot less you
mentioned about the environment and your
concerns about the environment and I was
wondering if you could talk just just
briefly about climate change and how
it's affecting cape dorset it's affected
the community I know it did when two
young men lost their lives because where
there used to be ice they lost their
lives going through the ice so that's
one very clear thing for sure that's
heartbreaking it is early melt ice
melting means less time out on the land
you know fishing though that it's
affected our lives it's just everyday
life nobody gone very
sometimes scary scary how you know you I
worry about what if we don't get much
food from the sea anymore or from the
land yes now the cost of living appears
there hi but I'm wondering it's
interesting because your art is so
popular in the south maybe your art
helps people in the self see what's
really goin up goin on up here in the
north that we we don't see because maybe
the North doesn't get as much attention
as it should I hope it does son and to a
few I well back dirty dark drawing up a
polar bear with a coca-cola 10 floating
cannon cuz when i was in other one with
my son I'm i sell coca coca cola bear
you long save the polar bear back we see
coca-cola cans floating around him so
that's something and what was the name
of that image the the polar bear with
the the coke I think Jericho good the
irony Darren you are one of the most
famous and well-known artists of the
collection when I've been waiting in
line myself at these the the day of the
print collection has released yours or
images or some of the first to be sold
even before were the rest of us get
there why did you decide to go to Arctic
college to study to be a teacher and
something something challenging yeah
maybe we should we should teach our
children you know to do
things change when you're yeah well you
know put something in them so they grow
up and make changes um I'm curious what
advice would you give to young artists
trying to establish their career in the
north maybe not just in Cape Dorset but
but all across the North don't give up
don't give up there's many different
ways to every person has a different
toilet fine trying fun with what you're
good at work on it and look I know you
come from a family of famous artists
what do you think your father would
think of the success that you've had I
will you be so proud I'm I'm very sure
yes then go cook thank you so much yeah
we'll try to make you got
you